here's a couple of rules I've discovered
in 30 years of working with wealthy
people okay number one almost no one
statistically becomes a millionaire from
an inheritance so that's all just
mythology and bullcrap okay number two
millionaires do not do super fancy weird
extremely risky things and keep their
money they usually lose everything if
they do so the millionaires that we have
studied are fairly boring they put money
in things they understand and like for
me I buy growth stock type Mutual Funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth International that kind of thing
and I buy real estate that I pay cash
for